I read in the paper there was an
announcement that you are going to act
in the new movie with Bradley Cooper I'm
doing a star is born with Bradley Cooper
how does that come about well he asked
me to do it and when did he ask you he
asked me it was very it was actually it
was right after I performed for an event
for cancer research for Sean Parker and
I sang a jazz set and he was there that
night and he asked me shortly after that
when you won a Golden Globe for American
Horror Story right you played a hotel
owner who maintained her beauty by
drinking human blood yes which we all
like well actually I was drinking the
blood of young children that was
filtered through a system that who makes
those decisions like do they send you is
not me who sends it who do I send the
script to but how did he get in touch
with you oh well I called him I told him
I wanted to be on the show and he goes
okay really that sample was great but
you know but how many different Bradley
had to audition oh my god our brothers I
acted before I was the singer actually I
acted in New York since I was 13 years
old I was like one of those nerdy
theater kid you know girl yeah yeah I
went to Strasburg on 14th Street is
where right used to take the nine when
you win The Sopranos for something I did
one extra performance remember was that
fun yeah it was fun it was exciting I
was in high school I got a phone call
that they wanted me on The Sopranos it
was great he'd show at the time were you
excited when you won the Golden Globe
for American Horror Story is that a big
deal
it was a dream come true it was
completely door opening for me and in it
it meant a lot to for other reasons
because you know I think that people
when either they see me as the countess
or and the other performances that I've
done in the past that they think that
that's just me right and it's it's not
me it is something that takes a long
time to create it's something that I
work it's you know the countess is a
character that I you know her voice the
way I walk the clothing her candor the
way that she is
it meant a lot to me that I was
recognized for it because I think some
people just thought oh that's just me
are you all set with your ideas about
how you're going to do with stars born
have you watched the other two movies am
i all set I mean that's not I guess
that's not really me and Bradley's
creative process as a team you know what
is the process in other words have you
seen the other two movies the one with
Judy Garland and the one with Barbra
Streisand yes those movies yes I do I
think you could improve on that movie
well you know I don't want to I don't
want to give away what we're doing with
the film yeah because it's too early to
give it away but I will say that it's
very brilliant direction I love the
script I can't put it down when I read
it I cry when I read it the script is
done the script is done and it will be
forever I think kind of even forming
more and more as we lead up to film and
Bradley wrote the script Bradley didn't
write the script but he's very integral
in writing in writing the script and
also oh I shouldn't say he didn't write
it it he's Bradley is a star is born
right now you know he's living it this
is his passion project and he's brought
me on board and I'm very very honored to
be a part of it he's gonna direct it
he's gonna star in it he's becoming the
character you know as we speak what do
you mean he's becoming the character as
we speak do you saw him Saturday night
after you did Saturday night like he was
there to support you it was so nice I
walked offstage it was so crazy I walked
so I I mean it's so kind of cheesy but
the second I stopped singing million
reasons I just broke down into tears at
the piano as soon as they yelled cut and
I'm walking off and my eyes get really
fill me after why did you start crying I
just it was just such a release you know
it was like I've been waiting three
years to put out a pop album and and I
couldn't wait to put it out I couldn't
wait to sing this music the lyrics of
the song mean a lot to me I think it's
something that people really need to
hear right now it's a stressful time in
the world and when it was done I just
felt relieved and I was crying and I
walked off and Bradley was right there
and dave chappelle was was was there
with them and it was just kind of really
sweet they both gave me a big hug and
they were like you did it do you think
Bradley is in the process of forming a
bond with you so that you'll
fall in love with him in a sense so that
when you play this movie together that
the relationship will be fully realized
well I mean it sounds like he's got some
sort of thing it's not like that it's
Bradley is a professional right Bradley
is a household human being in every way
I mean I can't tell you the level of
professionalism I experienced with him
working I think more than anything that
we have a very honest and authentic
relationship and that we just friends it
seems like like this is a lot of
together time before you even make the
movie it's almost like you two are
trying to get to know each other but
that's how I am with everything that I
do so Warner Brothers why did they make
you audition they've seen you on
American Horror Story you won the the
Lord the Golden Globe you've been acting
why did Warner Brothers need to audition
you I don't know but I'm fine with it
you were okay what was the audition you
did a scene from the movie yeah I did a
scene with Bradley we shot it and it was
great and I showed my stuff and I got
the job it feels good to work for
something you know it's like you know
which once you make it in a way it's
less fun when everybody just hands you
[ __ ] like it's so much more fun when
they're like you know the audition I'm
like I'm like [ __ ] keep that
[ __ ] on the phone let's do this
[ __ ] like come on like send me the
script where are we filming let's go I
get I get excited this is a romantic
movie this is a movie that is a love
story as well as a story about the you
know the inner sort of behind the scenes
workings of becoming a star and I'm
ready to do love scenes on camera with
Bradley Cooper I've already done love
plenty of love scenes and can i yes I'm
afraid you're gonna be able to be
professional and not put your hands
where they shouldn't be do you think a
true romance could have come out of this
I'm thinking maybe absolutely not no way
no absolutely you know as well as I do
as an actor that you've you can fall in
love so easily on this set you know it
but I already you know the thing is is
that I already love everyone you know
and the idea is if you really love some
buddy you you you put the most important
thing first and that is the film and the
truth is what's most important to me is
that we tell a story that touches the
hearts of the millions of people that
come to see it